Bonjour tout le monde, et bienvenue dans une nouvelle vidéo. Aujourd'hui, je
voulais vous
raconter la fois où j'ai travaillé dans une ferme au Japon. En réalité, j'ai
travaillé dans plusieurs
fermes et du coup, je voulais vous parler de cette expérience. Alors, pour
commencer, pourquoi est-ce
que je suis allé au Japon et pourquoi est-ce que j'ai travaillé dans une ferme ?
Donc en 2020,
avec ma femme, on est allés pour la première fois au Japon et on est tombés
amoureux du pays.
À partir de ce moment-là, on a commencé à prévoir un voyage d'un an. Donc, on a
commencé à
économiser de l'argent et on a commencé à essayer de planifier un voyage d'un an
avec le visa vacances
travail. Ce qu'on a fait, du coup, c'est qu'on a bien sûr économisé et on a
économisé pour essayer
de ne pas avoir à trop travailler une fois sur place. Si on partait avec peu
d'argent, on aurait été
bloqués dans des villes comme Tokyo avec un petit boulot, avec un petit travail
et on voulait éviter
ça. On voulait vraiment profiter de cette année pour voyager. Et ce qu'on a
découvert, enfin,
une chose qu'on nous a recommandé, c'est de faire du woofing. Donc le woofing,
en fait,
c'est un concept qui permet d'aller travailler dans des fermes, dans n'importe
quel pays et en
échange, vous n'êtes pas payés, mais vous êtes logés et nourris. C'est-à-dire
que vous habitez
avec les personnes et elles vous préparent à manger. Donc, vous travaillez et en
échange,
vous ne payez rien. Et ça, c'était assez idéal pour voyager sans que ce soit
trop difficile d'un
point de vue du budget. Et du coup, on a commencé à prévoir un peu ça pour
prévoir tout simplement
de faire ce genre de travail pour ne pas avoir à trop dépenser d'argent. Ce
qu'on a fait,
du coup, c'est qu'on est partis au Japon et après, une fois sur place, on a
commencé à chercher des
endroits où travailler. Je vais vous montrer ça. Donc, en gros, il y a un site
internet qui s'appelle
woof Japan et vous avez, je pense, la même chose pour n'importe quel pays. Il
existe la même chose en
France, donc si ça vous intéresse, je vous recommande de regarder le site
français. Et il y a un autre
site qui est très connu pour ce genre de travail, mais je ne me souviens pas le
nom. Donc là,
en fait, le principe est assez simple. Vous devez vous inscrire et vous devez
payer pour accéder au
site. Vous payez, je crois que c'est écrit ici, mais ça doit être environ 40, 50
euros, 40 euros
maintenant à l'année pour rejoindre le site. Donc, ce n'est pas très cher, il
faut quand même payer,
mais ce n'est pas très cher. Et après, en fait, vous accédez à une liste de
personnes de fermes
qui accueillent des woofers, donc les personnes qui font du woofing, on appelle
ça des woofers. Du
coup, là, vous voyez que voilà, j'ai la carte du Japon et selon les régions,
donc Hokkaido,
c'est l'île tout au Nord, selon les régions, on peut trouver des fermes où
travailler. Si je mets
au hasard, voilà, là, vous voyez, il y a deux fermes. Malheureusement, elles ne
recherchent pas
de woofers pour le moment, mais c'est comme ça qu'on a trouvé les adresses où on
a travaillé.
Et ensuite, c'est assez simple, c'est vous contacter les personnes, vous dites,
j'aimerais
travailler dans votre ferme de telle date à telle date et ensuite, la personne
va vous répondre oui
ou non, tout simplement. Ce qui est un peu spécial, c'est que nous, on a voyagé
après le
Covid. Et en fait, quand j'ai essayé de contacter des fermes, je me suis rendu
compte que beaucoup
de fermes qui étaient inscrites et qui étaient actives avant le Covid ne
l'étaient plus après,
c'est-à-dire qu'elles ne répondaient plus vraiment au message après le Covid.
Quand on va sur la page
d'une ferme, on peut voir des reviews des woofers. Et là, en fait, je voyais
qu'à partir de 2020,
ça se stoppait net. Et nous, on est partis un an en 2024, ce qui veut dire que
depuis ce moment-là,
il n'y avait pas eu d'autres woofers. Mais malgré ça, il y avait quand même
beaucoup de
fermes qui cherchaient des personnes pour travailler. La raison, elle est assez
simple, c'est que en
général, c'est des fermes organiques, c'est-à-dire c'est des fermes bio qui
n'utilisent pas de
produits chimiques. Et ça, ça implique beaucoup de travail manuel. Et du coup,
ça implique d'avoir,
entre guillemets, de la main-d'œuvre. Donc, la main-d'œuvre, c'est les personnes
qui travaillent.
Il faut de la main-d'œuvre pour s'occuper des champs. Et c'est pour ça qu'ils
font appel à
des woofers. Ce n'est pas très cher. Il faut les loger, il faut les nourrir. Et
en échange,
il travaille pour vous. Donc, c'est un bon compromis. Et pour nous, en tant que
woofers,
ça nous permet de vraiment nous immerger dans la culture japonaise. Donc, si je
passe
sur Google Maps, on a la carte du Japon, pardon. Et donc, il y a Tokyo ici.
Nous, on a fait...
attendez, je me rappelle même plus. On a fait un woofing par ici dans les
montagnes. On a fait
un autre woofing par ici. Et on a fait un woofing par ici. Donc, en gros, ce
qu'on a commencé à
faire, c'est que pour le premier woofing, je vais repasser sur cette fenêtre.
Pour le premier
woofing, en fait, on est arrivés à Tokyo... on est arrivés à Tokyo début
février. On a... on
avait loué dix jours ou une semaine de Airbnb pour trouver une colocation. On a
trouvé une
colocation. On est resté un mois à Tokyo pour faire tout ce qui est
administratif, parce qu'il fallait
qu'on se déclare à la mairie, il fallait qu'on fasse des démarches, qu'on ouvre
un compte bancaire,
qu'on s'inscrive à la sécurité sociale, donc la... une sorte de sécurité santé,
donc healthcare,
avant de commencer vraiment notre année. On a fait ça. Ensuite, on a voyagé
un mois. Et après,
on a fait notre premier woofing où là, on a commencé par un mois de woofing,
donc quatre
semaines. On a contacté les personnes. La ferme dans laquelle on est allé,
c'était une recommandation
d'une... de quelqu'un que je connais qui... qui avait déjà fait cette expérience
et qui m'avait
recommandé cette ferme. Et on y est allé un mois. Et là, quand on arrive, ben du
coup, la famille en
fait nous explique comment ça va se passer, nos horaires de travail, etc. etc.
Ça, c'est des choses
dont on peut parler en amont, c'est-à-dire avant, pendant qu'on échange des
messages en fait. Et voilà,
la personne, donc là, c'était un couple de Japonais qui... je pense qu'ils
avaient, dans les
70 ans, donc assez plutôt âgés, et ils nous expliquent ce qu'on va faire, etc.
Dès le lendemain,
on a commencé à travailler. Et là, si je me souviens bien, le premier matin, en
fait, on faisait
du packing. C'est-à-dire que eux, ils ramassaient les légumes et nous, on
faisait des... on pesait
les légumes et on faisait des... des petits paquets pour les vendre ensuite. On
a fait ça et après,
l'après-midi, on a fait des semis, je crois. Donc, semis, c'est quand on met les
graines. Enfin,
on a... on a planté des petites graines dans des petits pots pour préparer les
prochaines
plantations. Mais en gros, du coup, la ferme, elle était principalement...
c'était... c'était
principalement que des légumes. Et du coup, ça se résumait à... ça se résumait à
préparer les
plantations pour la saison prochaine, planter, récolter et faire du désherbage.
Donc, le désherbage,
c'est quand on enlève l'herbe. Quand il y a des mauvaises herbes, il faut
désherber et ça,
comme ils n'utilisaient pas de produits chimiques, on devait le faire manuellement.
Et c'était
beaucoup de travail. Mais au-delà du travail, en fait, ça a vraiment été... en
fait, avant de
partir au Japon, on avait un peu peur d'avoir cette barrière en tant qu'étranger
avec les locaux.
C'est-à-dire que, bon, déjà, on apprenait le Japonais et on pouvait parler un
petit peu
japonais. Donc, c'était un avantage. Mais quand même, quand vous êtes à Tokyo,
il n'y a pas
beaucoup de Japonais qui vont venir vous parler comme ça. Et en fait, ça,
c'était l'expérience
idéale parce que là, d'un coup, on se retrouvait à vivre dans une famille
japonaise. Donc,
vraiment à la japonaise, dans une maison japonaise, avec des Japonais. Et
c'était vraiment génial.
Ça, pour le coup, ça a vraiment cassé cette barrière qu'on pouvait avoir, qu'on
aurait pu avoir
avec les Japonais et la culture japonaise. Et là, c'était vraiment... on se
serait cru dans un
Ghibli avec... on dormait dans une pièce avec des tatamis sur des futons et
c'était vraiment 100%
japonais. Et après, le travail, pour le coup, dans ce woofing, c'était très...
comment dire ? C'était
très à la japonaise. C'est-à-dire que tout était bien réglé et que, quand
c'était l'heure de fin
du travail, c'était fini. Une fois, je crois qu'on a travaillé quatre minutes de
plus et ils se sont
vraiment excusés pour nous dire désolé, on vous a fait travailler plus et tout.
C'est bon,
c'est bon. Donc, c'était vraiment très carré, très respectueux et ce couple-là
était vraiment,
avait vraiment envie d'échanger. La dame parlait anglais, donc ce n'était pas un
problème de
communication, mais comme on voulait apprendre le japonais, elle essayait de
nous parler en
japonais et surtout, elle parlait plus lentement et si on ne comprenait pas,
elle reformulait sa
phrase, elle répétait sa phrase mais avec d'autres mots. Et ça, c'est vraiment
l'idéal parce que
quand vous avez en face de vous quelqu'un qui sait faire ça, c'est hyper
agréable pour apprendre.
Si je vous donne un autre exemple, quand je suis allé ouvrir mon compte en
banque, la personne au
comptoir, elle parlait super vite japonais. Je lui disais, je ne suis pas sûr de
comprendre est-ce que
vous pouvez répéter plus lentement, elle me regardait, elle redisait la même
phrase à la même
vitesse. Cette personne, peut-être qu'elle n'aimait pas vraiment les étrangers,
mais du moins,
elle n'avait pas cette compétence à parler lentement, reformuler, répéter les
phrases avec
d'autres mots. Du coup, c'était compliqué. Mais là, c'était tout l'inverse et du
coup,
on a passé vraiment quatre semaines géniales. Le travail, c'était quand même
assez physique.
Le travail à la ferme de manière générale, c'est assez physique et notamment
quand il faut
désherber parce qu'il faut se pencher en avant, enfin il faut se pencher pour
tout désherber. Donc,
on est un peu plié en deux. Les japonais et les asiatiques de manière générale,
eux,
ils peuvent faire le asian squat. Je ne sais pas si vous voyez, mais c'est
quand vous êtes
accroupi. Pour moi et pour ma femme, par exemple, ça, ce n'est pas une position
de repos. Et du
coup, on avait du mal pour ça à faire le désherbage, etc. Mais voilà, au global,
c'était vraiment une super expérience. Et à la fin de cette première expérience,
on a participé au festival du village. C'était à côté d'une ville, mais c'était
dans un
petit village. On a participé au festival et là, c'était incroyable au sens
propre du
terme. C'est-à-dire qu'on s'est retrouvé avec toutes les personnes du village
assis dans le temple,
à boire de l'alcool avec le prêtre, etc. Et on était vraiment les deux seules
étrangers,
les deux seules blancs. Et c'était incroyable. C'était même impressionnant de se
dire qu'est-ce
qu'on fait là parce qu'est-ce qu'on a notre place, etc. Mais bon, très
rapidement, quand vous avez
tous les hommes du village qui vous reservent de l'alcool et que dès que vous
avez bu un peu,
ils vous reservent. Au bout d'un moment, vous n'avez plus trop de gêne, vous
êtes saoul. Et c'est
très marrant. Enfin, je n'aurais pas imaginé qu'on puisse se retrouver dans ce
genre de situations.
Et donc pour ça, le woofing, c'est vraiment extraordinaire dans le sens où ça
casse
énormément de barrières et on se retrouve dans des situations où en tant que
touriste,
on n'aurait jamais pu être. Donc si à un moment, vous voyagez en France et que
vous
vous posez la question, je vous recommande très fortement. Bien évidemment, il
faut faire attention
à où on va. Je m'explique. Sur le site, dans les listes, à chaque fois, il y a
des reviews des
woofer. Et ça, il faut regarder parce que parfois, vous allez, enfin, j'ai
entendu parler d'endroits où
c'était un peu de l'exploitation. C'est-à-dire que ce n'était pas vraiment des
personnes qui étaient
ouvertes à l'échange et elles faisaient ça surtout pour avoir des personnes qui
travaillent
gratuitement. Et ça, c'est dommage. Enfin, ce n'est pas trop l'esprit du
woofing. Donc si vous êtes
dans ce genre de situations, vous pouvez partir et vous pouvez essayer de
trouver un autre endroit.
Mais du coup, il faut faire attention quand on cherche pour être sûr de trouver
le bon endroit.
Mais après, de manière générale, dans les commentaires, ce genre de ferme comme
la première
où on est allés, ils nous ont énormément de bons commentaires. Les gens sont
ravis. Donc vous
voyez rapidement que c'est un bon endroit. Et après, du coup, on est allé dans
deux autres
endroits. On est allé dans un endroit où c'était des Japonais mais des versions
hippies. Donc ça
contrastait beaucoup avec l'expérience précédente. Et là, c'était vraiment une
colonie de vacances.
Donc on était huit ou neuf woofers. Donc ce qui est énorme, enfin ce qui est
beaucoup. Et du
coup, ce qui était dommage, c'est qu'on avait moins de lien avec la famille
parce qu'il ne pouvait
pas tout partager avec neuf personnes. Mais du coup, nous tous, les huit
ensemble, ça a fait une
sorte de colonie de vacances où la journée, on travaillait tous ensemble.
C'était marrant. Et
nos jours off, donc les jours où on ne travaillait pas, là, on partait faire
plein de choses ensemble.
Et voilà, il y a des fois où on est allés tous ensemble avec la famille pêcher
dans la mer du
Japon, aller voir le coucher de soleil et aller à la plage, etc. Et ça, c'était
vraiment pareil.
C'était des moments inoubliables. Et d'ailleurs, on a gardé des amis de ce woofing
et on a rencontré
un Français. Et si on va au Japon, on a deux amis qui ont maintenant un enfant.
Et du coup,
je pense qu'on ira les voir si on va au Japon cette année. Et là, bon, le
travail, c'était très
différent. Ce n'était pas vraiment des champs. En fait, la personne, je ne sais
pas si vous avez
déjà vu, mais au Japon, dans la campagne, vous pouvez acheter des maisons pour
rien. Vous pouvez
acheter des maisons, des vieilles maisons pour très peu d'argent. Et là, la
personne, ce qu'elle
faisait, c'est que, comme ces vieilles maisons, elles sont un peu abandonnées.
Souvent, elles sont
laissées telles qu'elles. Elles sont laissées dans leur état au moment où,
voilà, c'est souvent
des vieilles personnes qui décèdent et les enfants essaient de vendre la maison.
Mais comme c'est
dans la campagne, ils ne peuvent pas vendre très cher. Et du coup, quand vous
achetez la maison,
en général, il y a tout dedans. Et là, la personne, en fait, elle achetait des
maisons autour pour
faire des sortes de Airbnb en quelque sorte. Et après, elle prenait des
woofers pour nettoyer
les maisons. On a fait ça, il y avait des maisons. Et pour vous dire, je crois
que la petite maison
japonaise avec la rizière*, bon, pas en très bon état, une très vieille maison,
mais il en avait
acheté une pour moins de 1000 euros, je crois. Moins de 1000 euros, une maison
au Japon. Il y avait
beaucoup de travail, il y avait beaucoup de ménages à faire dans cette maison,
mais c'est peut-être
une idée de retraite. Et qu'est-ce qu'on a fait d'autre ? Bon là, c'était quand
même plus roots,
c'était vraiment dans la nature. Il y avait des araignées énormes, il y avait
des serpents,
et il y avait ce qu'ils appellent des Suzumebachi, c'est comme des frelons,
comme des très grosses abeilles, des frelons asiatiques, des frelons japonais,
mais géants,
des frelons géants. Je pense qu'un frelon, il pouvait faire la taille de mon
pousse et quand
on leur a demandé « est-ce que c'est dangereux ? », ils nous ont dit « you can
die ». On était
« ok, ok ». Et du coup ça, on faisait attention et parfois c'était un peu
flippant, un peu inquiétant
parce qu'on devait aller désherber, enlever des herbes dans un endroit. Il y
avait des
serpents, des araignées, des Suzumebachi, et du coup on devait faire attention.
On a aussi
planté du riz dans les risières, pieds nus, vraiment à la roots et là c'était
aussi une
expérience assez particulière. Après, on a fait un autre woofing au bord de la
mer,
là aussi, vers Nagoya, et là c'était un peu comme le premier, assez classique.
La seule chose,
c'est qu'au Japon, en été, il fait super chaud et humide, donc c'est vraiment,
je ne pensais pas
que c'était possible à ce point-là. En ressenti, donc normalement sur la météo,
vous avez aujourd'hui
il fait 33 degrés, ressenti 37 par exemple. Selon s'il y a de l'humidité, le
ressenti va être
plus élevé. Et là, à cet endroit, mais aussi à Tokyo, tout l'été, c'était un
ressenti d'au moins
40 degrés tous les jours, je crois. Donc l'été au Japon, il fait super, super
chaud. Et là,
du coup, on commençait, on travaillait de 6 heures à midi le matin. Donc on se
levait très
tôt, on travaillait à 6 heures, on faisait une petite pause, petit déjeuner vers
7h30 8 heures,
on finissait de travailler et l'après-midi on était libre. Bon, ils faisaient
super chaud,
donc on ne faisait pas grand-chose, mais il y avait la mer à côté et il y avait
des planches de surf
disponibles. Donc je suis allé surfer plusieurs fois de ce côté-là dans le
Pacifique. Après
cette expérience, on est retourné dans le premier, comme on avait adoré notre
expérience, on est
retourné faire du woofing, travailler dans la première ferme. Et voilà. Et en
fait, voilà,
je voulais parler de cette expérience parce que c'était vraiment des moments
uniques et qu'on
n'aurait pas pu vivre tout seul, enfin, sans faire ce genre d'expérience. On
n'aurait pu, mais il
aurait vraiment fallu d'un gros coup de chance. Et là, finalement, c'était entre
guillemets
économique pour nous et en même temps, ça nous a ouvert énormément de portes.
Donc ça,
c'était vraiment génial. Une autre fois, pendant un woofing, on est allés chez
des amis des
personnes pour couper des pousses de bambou. Donc les bambous, quand ils
commencent à pousser,
on les coupe et on les découpe et en fait, après, on peut les manger. Et ça, on
est allé. On
parait, on s'est retrouvé dans la campagne japonaise, pas un étranger en vue. Il
n'y avait
personne d'étranger à part nous. Et là, on s'est retrouvé dans cette vieille
maison à découper
les pousses de bambou, ce genre de choses. Donc voilà, que des expériences
uniques et vraiment
inoubliables. Et juste avant le premier woofing, on avait fait un mois de voyage
dans le sud où on
allait de ville en ville. Et en fait, là, on a vraiment vu la différence entre
faire un voyage où
on reste un peu dans des sortes d'hôtels à chaque fois, où on fait les sites
touristiques et ensuite,
on change de ville, à là où on passait un mois au même endroit. On ne voyait pas
autant de sites
touristiques, mais finalement, l'expérience était beaucoup plus marquante, elle
était beaucoup plus
inoubliable. Et à partir de là, en fait, on a un peu changé notre vision de ce
voyage et on a
pris beaucoup plus le temps d'aller rencontrer les gens. Et voilà, si des amis
nous disaient,
ah, vous pouvez aller voir un tel, je connais un ami qui habite là-bas, on le
faisait parce qu'on
savait que ça allait sûrement être une expérience inoubliable. Donc voilà, ce
qu'on retient
surtout de ce voyage, c'est surtout les rencontres au-delà de vraiment avoir vu
des sites touristiques
du Japon. Je ne veux pas faire la morale, mais voilà, juste pour vous dire que
si vous avez envie de
voyager en France, n'hésitez pas à sortir un peu des sentiers battus, à un peu
sortir du guide
touristique à Paris. À Paris, c'est magnifique, il y a plein de choses à voir.
Donc si vous n'êtes
jamais allé à Paris, ça vaut le coup. Mais voilà, si vous y êtes déjà allé,
n'hésitez pas à
sortir un peu pourquoi pas faire du woofing. Et là, vous allez vivre vraiment la
vie française à
100%. C'est un conseil, vous faites ce que vous voulez. En tout cas, j'espère
que vous avez aimé
cette vidéo. J'essaye en ce moment de faire des vidéos moins orientées sur
l'apprentissage en
tant que tel parce qu'à force, ça devient un peu répétitif. Et puis je me dis
que ça peut être
intéressant pour vous d'entendre ce genre d'histoire. Merci d'avoir regardé
jusqu'au bout et je vous dis à
à la prochaine.